twenty-one Savage is a free man at least
for now the rapper whose real name is
shape and Abraham Joseph was released on
bond following his arrest in Atlanta by
immigration and customs enforcement on
Tuesday in a statement to ET his legal
team states that Savage was granted an
expedited hearing explaining quote for
the past nine long days we have been
speaking with ice
- both clarify his actual legal standing
his eligibility for bond and provide
evidence of his extraordinary
contributions to his community and
society the entertainer was arrested by
ice on Super Bowl Sunday in the process
it was revealed that he's a British
national who is in the country illegally
after his non-immigrant visa expired in
2006 when the rapper was a minor
according to his legal team it expired
through no fault of his own savage
missed the Grammys as a result of his
arrest and on Tuesday his legal team
delivered this message to fans who were
expecting him to perform quote he says
that while he wasn't present at the
Grammy Awards he was there in spirit and
is grateful for the support from around
the world and is more than ever ready to
be with his loved ones and continue
making music that brings people together
the statement ended with this powerful
message quote he will not forget this
ordeal or any of the father's son's
family members and faceless people he
was locked up with or that remain
unjustly incarcerated across the country
and he asks for your hearts and minds to
be with them last week ET caught up with
the rapper's friend wale who commented
on reports that jay-z's Roc Nation hired
legal help for savage no you know 20 you
know
money is not a issue at all you know but
there's things that are bigger right now
that we are trying to as a culture
trying to figure out right now but you
know my prayers is with him and his
family I know he has the children that
he loves to death and I know he's wanted
a really really really down our smart
brothers in his and his business he come
from a good family and I just want to
see good things up what's it like to see
the hip-hop community kind of rally
behind 21 Savage it's refreshing it's
bittersweet I wish you didn't have to
happen but I'm glad to know that I can
happen if it
[Music]
[Applause]